notre page cinéma maintenant pour
terminer ou presque aujourd'hui sur les
écrans français le film d'alain resnais
mon oncle d'amérique un film qui a été
très bien accueilli à cannes et qui peut
prétendre à figurer au palmarès cette
oeuvre qui relate l'histoire de deux
hommes et d'une femme est directement
adapté des travaux d'un sociaux
biologiste henri-laborit qui explique
d'abord à monique attenant comment il a
rencontré le metteur en scène alain
resnais
je pense que seul rennais pour moi seul
rennais était capable de réaliser un
film comme celui-là d'abord parce que
reynet qu'un homme qui en plus d'un gène
d'un génie
du cinéma ce qui je répète les pas de
mon domaine donc est un homme
extrêmement consciencieux et à passer
d'abord quatre ans avec moi savent hamdi
commence à dire la borie j'en ai jusque
là parce que il a tout lu il a il a
travaillé vraiment pour s'incorporer les
notions souvent difficile et en réduire
ce qui peut être compréhensible à la
majorité des hommes c'est très important
pour toi qu'est ce que tu racontes
sigefi et pourquoi j'ai choisi forcément
regarder la réalité en face
en vingt ans tu vas et qu'un exécutant
aujourd'hui tu prendrais une pareille
responsabilité pourquoi pas ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir qu'ils sont
emprisonnés dans un an dans un certain
nombre de conditionnement qui sont dans
lequel que l'on place dans leur système
nerveux depuis leur naissance
et ça ça débouche sur un comportement
social interindividuelle intergroupe
sociaux un terreau et à un tiers blog
d'état aujourd'hui sur cette planète
et que tout ça vient de la fin de ce
qu'est le cerveau humain ci avait pas de
cerveau dans les individus y aurait pas
l'individu joint avec leurs envies
normand jours agissant sur l'environnent
leur environnement et l'environnement je
tiens à dire que c'est pas simplement
les espaces verts
c'est l'autre homme d'abord important
comment que ce message soit entendu
je vais très très franc demain je ne
serai pas là enfin je ne serai pas à la
can mais sûrement faire j'aurais disparu
de la planète et l'avenir de cette
espèce m'intéresse relativement peu
wi fi
et pour faire plaisir g au fond ils vont
me demander quelles étaient les
conditions d'une rencontre entre un
prétendu scientifiques fous pas quand
même prendre au sérieux et bien cinéaste
et la première sécu j'étais très flatté
mois que le seul signe à ce que
j'admirais vraiment très totalement
s'intéresse que ce que j'avais écrit est
ce que j'avais fait ce que je pensais
si vous voulez mon narcissisme été
satisfaits d'autre part ma situation
scientifiques ayant été toujours une
situation marginale et ça ne me
déplaisait pas si tu es sont marginales
dans calais la socio culturel mais mon
environnement social m'avait confirmé
ces débats c'était toujours c'est
toujours bilatérales comportement humain
j'étais pas des débats mécontents de
d'ajouter cette marginalité une
contribution une oeuvre d'art
ja la majorité de ce qui est dit je les
écris il ya quinze ou vingt ans le jeu
mais ça n'entrait pas dans le dans le 6
et 9 ans mes contemporains c'est à dire
que l'ensemble de l'évolution de la
pensée contemporaine n'était pas prête à
le recevoir
actuellement nous atteignons un
ras-le-bol que les mouvements
écologiques que les perturbations
sociales partout à travers le monde et
nous l'ont de dif devenir de plus en
plus insupportable on ne donne pas
d'explication
explication les pourtant dans celle dans
le fonctionnement du cerveau humain
elle est par ailleurs titre du film
d'alain resnais donc mon oncle
d'amérique bord